نتواجد في هذا الموقع في البراهيم لتحديدا
في غازي عنتاب حيث عشرات
المباني المخدمه التي استلمها الفريق
الانقاذ السعودي منذ يومين ويتم العمل على
مدار الساعه على مدار 24 ساعه في هذا
الموقع وفي مواقع مختلفه في عمليات
الانقاذ وعمليات ايضا انتشال الجثث حتى
هذه اللحظه والاعمال لا زالت بسيطه جدا مع
مرور سبعه ايام حتى الان تحدث عن اكثر من
150 ساعه رائحه الجثث احمد بدات تنتشر
بشكل كبير جدا في هذا الموقع الكثير من
الجثث تم انتشالها قبل ساعات حيث تم
انتشار ما يقارب سبعه جثث وايضا في
اللحظات القليله الماضيه كان هنالك ايضا
جثه تم انتشالها في هذا الموقع حيث اب
يحمل ابنه الصغير وهو محتضنه في هذا
الموقع تم انتشار هذه الجثه في
في هذا الوضع حقيقه الوضع ماساوي في هذا
الموقع تحديدا حيث نتحدث عن عشرات الاسر
المتواجده في هذا الموقع
ينتظرون اي بصيص امل لاي خبر عن ذويهم في
هذا الموقع وهم يتسمرون في هذا الموقع منذ
ايام في لحظات ترقب وتامل
وامل ولو كان بسيطا مع مرور سبعه ايام
واعتضاء الفرص بشكل كبير جدا
لانتشال ايه او ايجاد ايه مفقودين ولكن
الاخبار